when when men are in a locker room
together speech is very unfiltered they
make stupid jokes they may I mean I've
never been in one but I have heard you
know my brothers amongst friends and
it's like as a chick you hear certain
stuff and you're like oh my gosh this is
how guys talk but it's funny because you
know the manosphere is the man's space
on YouTube and it's so interesting
because whenever men have a space or
they can just talk freely women feel the
need to police it so that's where you'll
get women that come in and say well it's
about how you say it you need to say it
in a more feminine way is essentially
what they're saying and that's why you
can kind of tell when men are like led
by some women in their lives because
they're always going to come in and say
it's your tone it's the way you say it
rather than is the information correct